welome back Leah Thomas Made Global
headlines when she became the first
transgender person to win a national
college title swimming leading to
outrage from the women she defeated she
was ranked 65th when competing as a man
well three months after that win she was
banned from competing against biological
women but she's now maned a legal fight
to overturn the ban and has potentially
the Paris Olympics in her sights I'm
joined now by the former teammate of
Leah Thomas stand with women's
spokeswoman Paula scanland out kcks CEO
playay Travis and political journalist
and defender of the indefensible on
these things AA Santina so welcome to
all of you let me start with you uh if I
may pauler you have competed against
Leah Thomas in your estimation how
unfair is it that Leah Thomas was
allowed to compete against biological
females and is now trying to seek legal
address to do so
potentially removing one woman from the
women's Olympic
team yeah it's incredibly unfair um I
think just looking at the situation Leah
Thomas was the tallest person on both
the men's and the women's team at the
University of Pennsylvania just the
height difference the muscle difference
the length in Bones the body shape um
and also the hormones that males have
that women don't that was obviously a
huge factor in Leah being much better
than the rest of us uh to put it into
perspective the University of
Pennsylvania has never had an NCAA
female champion until Leah Thomas came
around and I think that really shows
that our program went from hardly ever
having anyone qualify for the NCAA
Championship to having somebody win an
event and you you didn't actually
compete against her I think you competed
with her is that right yes I swam
different events than Leah but I was on
the same team right I mean I've just
seen you know some some of the video
clips from some of the races she was in
both when she competed as a man and then
as a woman and the difference is just
astounding I mean in One race she was
winning by over 50 seconds or something
crazy yeah and in that event actually
the second place finisher was a
University of Pennsylvania swimmer that
lost to Leah by over two laps in the
pool and if you were if you were a
member of the women's Olympic team for
the United States a woman and you lost
your place to Leah Thomas now how do you
think you'd
feel I would feel terrible and in fact
the girls that Leah beat when Leah won
the 500 yard freestyle the second third
and fourth place finisher were Olympian
themselves some of which having medals
so it already happened and it would
definitely happen in the Olympics and I
think that would be a big Scandal
because it would affect not just NCAA
athletes but all women from all
different countries that compete in the
sport of swimming and also in other
sports that they allow this to happen
and they will also be affected as well
right clay Travis I I've got a feeling
in like 10 years time maybe sooner we're
going to look back on this period of of
the existence of planet Earth and think
what the hell were we doing
how was this Insanity being allowed to
happen and it'll probably culminate in a
you know a 6' 6 in transgender athlete
winning the 100 meters women's race at
the Olympics by about 50 yards I mean
that's what's gonna
happen yeah I give credit to Paula uh
for speaking out and being willing to
point out how ridiculous this is because
I do think it's going to take women
athletes uh more so than people like you
and me Pier who can look at this and
talk about how ridiculous it is but what
we're starting to see is in America at
least when Gallop pulls this issue
increasingly massive majorities of the
American population are saying this is
wrong and Pierce I don't even think you
have to focus on sex itself uh obviously
men are bigger stronger and uh and
faster than women as a group and by the
way that doesn't mean that some women
aren't bigger stronger and faster than
some men which is
anally is it is why we separate the
genders at the Olympics I mean if you
made it gender if you had what there
would never be you had the woke dream of
a gender neutral Olympics can you
imagine how many actual women biological
females would win a medal I mean
literally other than probably equestrian
and shooting maybe that's
it yeah that's it that's it there would
be no women medalists that's why the the
separation occurs and by the way Pierce
what I focus on is I coach Little League
Sports I've got three boys
if I showed up for 12-year-old soccer uh
and I had a 16-year-old kid on my team
every parent would say no this is
unacceptable you can't do this can't do
it for baseball football basketball we
have all sorts of changes to regulations
you can't be trans AG right like I
couldn't suddenly decide that I'm going
to be a little Leaguer that's why they
asked for birth certificates so you can
go try to win the Little League World
Series because otherwise people would
cheat you know and if I suddenly said
I'm coaching I'm about to as soon as I
finish this interview Pierce uh I'm
going to go to seventh grade basketball
and watch my 13-year-old son uh
participate if if suddenly one of the
coaches came out on the court you know
64 and said hey I'm trans AG now sure
I'm 33 but I feel 13 everybody would
think it was ridiculous it's just the
very essence of sport itself yeah okay a
I'm looking at you frowning away here um
explain to me why this isn't just insane
that Leah Thomas who as we just heard
was not just the tallest boy in her
College when she was competing as a
biological male but the obviously the
tallest girl as well how can any of this
be fair I think okay so this is a really
interesting topic for someone who is
gender critical because on this show
before we have discussed puberty
blockers and whether children should be
allowed access to them when they are 12
13 years of age now boys develop when
they are 12 13 the second that they
start to have testosterone that is when
they they they grow bigger they have a
larger muscle mass than women if you
don't want to see trans women competing
in women's sports then you're going to
have to allow young children who do not
feel who are experiencing gender
dysphoria to have those drugs when
they're younger no not at all you are in
my estimation you do one of two things
it's very straightforward this whole
supposed insolvable problem is very
straightforward trans women either
compete against other trans women in an
entirely new category as there are more
and more as there are more and more of
them competing or they compete against
their biological sex because that is the
biology they've been born with tell me
why that's not fair I don't think it's
fair that people who have experienced
gender dysphoria when they're growing up
and don't feel that they are in the
right body should not be allowed to
compete in sports and if you're going to
take away their rights why don't you
care look you you love you go on about
women's rights a lot of the time I agree
with you I want women to enjoy utter
fairness and equality I think is fair
how can you possibly sign up to
something that is so grotesquely unfair
and unequal because Le to women's right
because Leah Thomas didn't wake up one
morning and suddenly decide I'm going to
be able to win in the women's category
so I'm going to that's exactly what
she's doing that's not that's not what
happen what she's doing De Thomas she is
she is a woman and so she is competing
as a woman she's a transwoman she is a
woman she's a transwoman we can go back
and forth she's a transwoman born with a
biological male body which gives her an
immediate massive advantage over women
who weren't so why aren't other members
of her team happy that they're finally
winning and qualifying for all of the
things that they never qualified for
because they can all see that it's is it
not a little bit of jealousy no it's
just they know that at some stage Leah
Thomas is going to probably win the
Olympic gold medal oh no that would be
awful for America would be terrible it
here's why it's terrible the United
States women's uh soccer team let's call
it soccer for the benefit of this
discussion because they call themselves
there were number one in the world the
best women's soccer players on the
planet and they got beaten I think it
was 8-1 by the Dallas under 15 boys team
right that is the point is that it
wasn't that the women's team weren't
great as a woman's team at soccer it's
to put them against a bunch of kids who
are male with male physiology they got
hammered okay that's why we separate the
Sexes so what do we say about trans
women then do we just say they're not
allowed to place forever are they I just
told you what we do they compete against
their biological sex which is perfectly
reasonable and fair that's not
reasonable it's perfectly reasonable by
the way solves the problem of the of the
dressing room too and who get let's talk
about all of those teenage years where
they would have been seeking medical
treatment and they weren't allowed
access to it now happening in the UK and
it's happening very much so in the US
people are being denied medical
treatment when they would like to have
it then when they get to a age you don't
let them Place sport you and I are going
to come back to this when someone like
Le Thomas wins an Olympic gold depriving
a woman of winning Olympic gold and
you're going to finally say Pi you were
right all
along